[Music]
industrial hemp research was authorized
in the 2014 farm bill Cornell as the
land-grant University in New York State
picked up very quickly to begin a pilot
program we started our hemp research in
the middle of the 2016 growing season
but really it took off in the 2017
growing season I was also asked by New
York State AG and markets in the
governor's office to lead an initiative
to plant 1,700 acres that support from
the governor's office and the
legislature in Ag and markets has really
put New York at the forefront of hemp
research in the country my research in
particular is to evaluate existing hemp
cultivars for their suitability in New
York conditions to be able to advise
farmers as to the best cultivars for
them to grow as they get started in the
hemp industry but also we're initiating
a long term and breeding program to
develop cultivars that are adapted for
New York conditions Cornell has
assembled a strong multidisciplinary
team of hemp researchers we're really
trying to cover all of the bases of hemp
research in the multidisciplinary
expertise that we have in the school of
integrated plant science at Cornell the
hemp industry overall has grown by leaps
and bounds across the country New York
is one of the leaders in hemp research
in the country
[Music]
you